hello everybody my name is markiplier
you may have noticed that this weekend
there has been nothing but multiplayer
pre-recorded videos that was not
intentional I have been sick and so I
have not been able to record a nation
because I have been sick so I didn't
have the energy to record anything else
but I had those so hope you enjoyed I
thought they're fine I'm done I've been
watching when I count well I was laying
in bed in agony oh I wrote my loving
adoring fan oh I cried myself to sleep
so hope you're happy everybody you our
expect videos tomorrow with me hopped up
on cold medicine and totally loopy out
of my mind which I know you guys like so
much but I just was not able to report
anything at all um
Judy's tiny little larva
okay okay
what doesn't so anyway I was changed the
battery pack however I'll be fine
I was going to say something where I was
Oh hazel that's good thing yeah um you
guys have been wanting omegle for a
while for me to do you know you've seen
the day before um now I'm going to do in
a Michael thing this week and it's going
to be this Saturday I'm going to do two
times so that people have opportunity to
find me Saturday noon will be on omegle
and Saturday 6:00 Eastern Standard Time
both times so put in in your shared
interests you put in markiplier
but markiplier as your shared interest
and it will connect you with people that
also like that thing and then you'll
talk to them or you'll see penises your
proxy pizzas not one piece and then I'll
record it wherever I find who's not a
penis I'll put it up on youtube so I can
see
okay okay
I'm gonna go lay down so thanks so much
for watching see you next one bye bye